[Music]
foreign
Nathan Brad I'm the new English teacher
you live near here
yeah the old Biddle house
the bill house
I did hear the horrible story about the
boy who used to live there
you know I hear it's haunted
have you seen anything
strange happening there
no
not that I can think of
[Music]
some weird stuff has been happening
something's clearly wrong
[Music]
time are you okay
this is all connected
he's getting revenge so what our parents
did to him
oh my God remember Napo babies
what's going on it's obvious you know
that's why all of this is happening to
us
[Music]
I have no choice this ends no
it's time for them to learn the truth
come with me
[Music]
we need to talk why does James smell
like watermelon Jolly Ranchers
[Music]
thank you